PROFESSOR: Another strange
observation about mirrors that
I've never really understood--
the mirror plane is reflecting
me left to right, so it looks
as though a mirror has
a grain to it.
It knows what line to reflect
me back and forth.
But if I kept the mirror in
fixed orientation and I lay
down, the thing should
reflect me side to
side, but it doesn't.
It still reflects me
from top to bottom.
So how can that be?
Why does a mirror plane, if I
hold it in one orientation,
appear to have a direction
across which I'm reflected but
it doesn't follow
me if I move?
Know what I mean?
You have any explanation
of that?
Hmm?
AUDIENCE: Rotate
your eyes, too.
PROFESSOR: Rotate my eyes.
I can roll them around.
I can't rotate in any
other fashion.
That's strange.
I mean, you look at yourself
every morning--
several times, perhaps,
and you're reflected
always left to right.
And if you turn the
mirror, it doesn't
reflect you top to bottom.
Or conversely, you can leave the
mirror alone and you can--
why does a mirror plane just
reflect you left to right?
Ah.
I'll let you stew about
that one for a while.
And I can tell you that I know
of three papers in scientific
journals that tried
to explain this.
I can give you literature
citations, but you think about
it until our next meeting.
Why does it know which
way I'm oriented?
Ah, I can't think about it.
Alright, back to more
straightforward questions.
We are now about to embark on
a grand process of synthesis
which will take us the better
part of half a semester.
And we've identified our
four basic operations--
four basic one step
operations--
namely translation, reflection,
rotation, and for
the time being I'm going to look
just at two-dimensional
symmetries, so I'll leave
inversion out of the picture.
It's only defined in three
dimensions, and the logic
which I will follow will be to
first build up two-dimensional
symmetries and then we'll turn
them into three-dimensional
symmetries by picking another
translation that's not
coplanar with the first two.
So we're going to look for
the time being at just
two-dimensional symmetries.
The nice thing about doing this
is that the number of
two-dimensional symmetries is
relatively small, so we can
derive them rigorously
and exhaustively.
To do so in three dimensions is
a much more time consuming
and elaborate exercise.
It's no different in principle,
there's just more work.
So if we do two-dimensional
symmetries first,
it's an easy case.
We can do it rigorously and
completely, and then what
we'll do is just look at a few
examples in three dimensions
and look at how the results are
designated and tabulated.
So the first combination I will
choose to make is one
that I set up last time and
should not have started when
there was no time
to finish it.
So let me take an initially
pristine space and say that to
this I'm going to the operation
of translation.
That immediately implies a
string of translations and a
string of lattice points, but
I'm just going to focus my
attention on the first one.
Then what I said I'll do is add
to the space a rotation
operation A alpha.
I'm going to for convenience
put it right at the lattice
point, but as there is no
unique origin to the
translation, I can start
and stop the
translation anywhere I like.
So here's my translation.
The rotation operation is going
to take that translation
and repeat it at angular
intervals alpha so that I get
a radiating porcupine-like
sheaf of translations all
coming out of a common point.
Alpha, we observed, has to be
a submultiple of 2 pi, so I
will have a cluster of
translations separated by the
equal interval alpha--
angular interval alpha--
and I'm going to choose to
focus my attention on
just the first one.
So this, since it's repeated
by rotation, has the same
length T.
And then I'm going to look
at the other end of the
translation and say that
similarly I must have a set of
equally spaced angular-wise
translations all separated by
alpha, and I'm going to choose
to focus my attention
just on this one.
So this angle is alpha, and
this angle here is alpha.
And now there's big trouble
in River City.
This is a translation, here's
a lattice point, here's a
lattice point.
This is a translation--
a lattice point sits up here.
a lattice points sits up here.
Now I've got two lattice points
eyeball to eyeball, and
they jolly well better be
separated by either the
interval T or some multiple
P times T,
where P is some integer.
It would be quite all right if
there were two translation
separation or five translation
separation, but it must be
some multiple of translation or
I have violated my initial
premise that everything in this
space is periodic at a
translational interval T.
So let me take this geometrical
constraint and
very quickly convert it into
analytical form so that we can
proceed to systematically
find out what the
possibilities are.
Let me drop a perpendicular
down to the original
translation.
So this distance in here is PT,
this distance will be T
times the cosine of alpha, and
this distance in here will be
T times the cosine of alpha.
So in analytic form, then, I
can say that my original
translation T is equal
to T cosine of alpha
plus T cosine of alpha.
That's 2T cosine of
alpha plus PT.
And the first thing we can see
is that the magnitude of T
drops out because this
construction and the
constraint it embodies in no way
depends on the magnitude
of the translation.
So this says, then, that 1 is
equal to 2 cosine of alpha
plus the integer P. And if I
solve for the value of cosine
of alpha, cosine of alpha will
be 1 minus an integer P
divided by 2.
So there is the constraint that
must be followed if my
construction is to be
self-consistent.
So we've got this now in a
plug and chug situation.
So what I'm going to put down is
the value of P, taking all
possible integers for
which a value of
cosine of alpha exists.
I'm then going to evaluate
cosine of alpha, which is 1
minus P over 2, and then I'm
going to identify the n-fold
axis that corresponds to that
particular value of alpha.
Let's put in P equals 3,
and this is as far
as we got last time.
Well, if we put 4, then cosine
of alpha is minus 3/2--
it's not defined.
If we drop P down to 3, then
cosine of alpha is minus 1, 1
minus 3 over 2.
And the angle whose cosine
is minus 1 is a--
let me put down the
value of alpha and
then the n-fold axis.
The angle whose cosine is minus
1 is 180 degrees, and
that would describe quite nicely
the rotational throw of
a twofold axis.
If I let P drop down to the
value 2, then I have minus 1/2
of the cosine of alpha.
The angle whose cosine is minus
1/2 is 120 degrees.
And guess what?
That's the angular throw
of a threefold axis.
Let P drop down to 1, and then
cosine of alpha is 0.
The angle whose cosine is 0 is
90 degrees, and that would be
a fourfold axis.
Looks like we're done, except
P could be equal to 0.
In that case, cosine of
alpha is plus 1/2.
The angle whose cosine is plus
1/2 is equal to 60 degrees,
and that's a sixfold access.
What about negative integers?
Minus one, will that work?
This says that cosine of alpha
is 1, and the angle whose
cosine is one is 0 degrees
or 360 degrees.
And that would be no rotational
symmetry all.
It's rather amusing that the
trivial case of no symmetry at
all also falls out of
this construction.
So this is a momentous result.
We've shown that if you're going
to have a pattern that
has a repetition by translation
in it, the number
of rotational symmetries that
can be added are either no
symmetry at all, a twofold
rotational symmetry,
threefold, fourfold,
or sixfold.
In other words, the axis--
no symmetry at all, twofold,
threefold, fourfold, or
sixfold, nothing else.
This tells you a lot about the
shapes that you can see
macroscopically on crystals.
You could have a crystal that
had the shape of the trigonal
prism, and that would
be perfectly fine.
You could have a crystal that
had the shape of an orthogonal
brick that would have twofold
axes coming out of the faces.
You could have a crystal in
the shape of a hexagonal
present, or you could have a
crystal in the shape of the
square prism.
But something thing like a
crystal with a pentagonal
cross section that would
be a fivefold access--
that is strictly forbidden,
because the external shape of
the crystal has to reflect the
internal symmetry among the
arrangement of atoms.
There are lots of things
in nature that have
crystallographic symmetry.
There is a little cactus that
looks like this with some
little spines coming out like
this on the top, and its
proper name is astrophytum
myriostigma, also known as the
ornamented bishops cap.
Beautiful example of fivefold
symmetry, but the cells inside
of that cactus can not have the
same size and shape and be
repeated by translation.
There are flowers that have
very common examples of
fivefold and even sevenfold
symmetry.
There's one little purple flower
that looks like this
that comes out in the spring,
and that's called periwinkle.
Fivefold symmetry-- fine for a
plant, but if you got down
inside the stem of this flower,
the cells cannot be
repeated by translation.
There are astronomically
high symmetries.
These big giant cacti in the
Southwest, the saguaro, they
have rotational symmetries
that run from 18-fold,
19-fold, 23-fold, so that if
you picked up one of these
guys very carefully, because
they're covered with spines,
and if you could lift it--
which would be very hard
because they weigh a
couple of tons--
take that guy and rotate them
through 1/27 of a circle, and
if he had 27-fold symmetry, you
could plop them down and
you couldn't tell that
it had been moved.
There is no crystallographer
who can resist cacti.
All sorts of symmetry, even
symmetries that violate
crystal graphic symmetries--
wonderful textures and colors.
And they have another really
remarkable property, which
commends them as house plants.
If they die, this sheath of
spines stays intact until
someday when you're watering it,
you brush against it and
you poke a hole right through
the spines and
there's nothing inside.
So a house plant that dies and
you can't tell for two years
or so is a very good plant
to have as a companion.
So cacti have all sorts
of strange symmetries.
Fine, but you can say something
about the internal
structure of that flower
or that cactus.
But this little almost trivial
proof has told us something
else about crystals, because
the presence of translation
imposes a constraint on the
rotational symmetry that can
be present, and the rotational
symmetry tells us something
about the nature of the
two-dimensional lattice which
can accommodate that symmetry.
So let's go through this list
once more, and let's pay
attention to the value of P.
For a twofold rotational
symmetry, what we would do
would be to take this original
translation, we put the
twofold axis here, and that
takes the translation and
rotates it around.
So here's a lattice point here,
one here, one here, and
the twofold axis here, takes the
translation and we rotate
in a counterclockwise sense.
Here's another lattice
point here.
P was equal to three
translations, and I'll be
darned if that isn't exactly
what we have.
Three translations from
this lattice point A--
let me put some labels
up here.
This was lattice point A, this
was lattice point B, and this
was our translation PT.
Three translations, just
as advertised.
What constraint does this
put on a lattice?
None whatsoever, because all
this says is that if you have
a translation that translation
must be repeated into an
extended one-dimensional row.
So you can put this an any
2D lattice whatsoever.
In other words, the magnitudes
of the two translations--
let's call them T1 and T2 are
under no constraint to be
related one to another--
and this angle between
them, alpha, can be
anything that it likes.
You could have a twofold axis,
but that requires simply a
lattice row parallel to T1 and
a lattice row parallel to T2.
The next integer we
hit was minus 1/2.
That was cosine of minus 1/2,
this was P equals 3, and that
corresponded to something
that could
accept a threefold symmetry.
So let me put a guide to the
I in here and make an
equilateral triangle.
If we translate and rotate
up by 120 degrees using a
threefold axis and then rotate
minus 120 degrees about the
other lattice point, that
puts another translation
up here, and now--
I'm sorry, this was P equals 2
And as required, this is PT,
and that's equal to
two translations.
This has put a constraint on the
sort of lattice which can
exist in this space because we
have two translations, T1 and
T2, which are equal in
magnitude, identical in
magnitude, because they're
related by symmetry.
And consequently, we have
defined a space lattice, a
two-dimensional space lattice.
We'll call this T1
and call this T2.
This lattice has the constraint
that magnitude of
T1 must be identical to the
magnitude of T2, and the angle
between T1 and T2 is again
identically 120 degrees.
Not 119.9, but exactly 120
degrees because there is a
threefold axis in here that
demands that that be so.
So this is a very specialized
kind of lattice, restricted to
have two translations identical
in magnitude.
And if there's a threefold axis
there, you should be able
to find these two.
And if there's a threefold axis
there, then the angle
between these two specialized
translations is 120 degrees.
Our next magic integer was 1,
and that corresponded to a
fourfold axis.
And if we do what we claimed we
did in that construction,
we'd put a fold axis here.
That takes T1 and rotates it
exactly 90 degrees to a
translation T2.
Once again, two noncollinear
translations, so we have
defined a two-dimensional net.
If we complete the cell, this
is one translation.
PT is equal to one translation
in here, and this angle is 90
degrees because it's produced
by a fourfold axis.
So we have a very
special lattice.
Again, the magnitudes of two
translations are identical--
not approximately the same,
they're identical--
and the angle between them is
identically 90 degrees.
Only a couple to go.
P could be equal to 0, and that
was the case for a 60
degree rotation,
a sixfold axis.
So again, let's draw what
came out of this
particular special case.
Here's T1, here is T2.
This angle is 60 degrees exactly
because there's a
six-fold rotation axis here, a
sixfold rotation axis here,
and the rotation of 60 in the
opposite sense gives us
another translation here.
These two lattice points
coincide and there is PT equal
to 0T, and these two
points coincide.
Now if I complete a standard
unit cell with T1 T2 as I've
done in other cases--
this was T1, this was T2, this
was a translation which I'm
not going to use.
So this is the shape of the
lattice and these now are
lattice points with a sixfold
axis on them.
The dimensional specialization
is exactly the same as I found
for a threefold axis,
T1 identical to T2.
If I pick this cell, T1 to T2
can be described as an angle
of 120 degrees.
Exactly the same lattice that we
found for a threefold axis.
So with this simple minded
little construction we've
found two profound things--
that there are five kinds of
rotation axes, including the
onefold no rotational
symmetry at all.
And it turns out that there are
one, a general lattice, a
hexagonal lattice, and
the square lattice.
There are three kinds of
two-dimensional lattices that
are required by these
symmetry elements.
So these guys require that
there be three lattice of
different specializations that
are able to accommodate them.
So let me call this a
parallelogram net, and that
has T1 not equal to
T2, the angle
between T1 and T2 general.
And this is a lattice that can
accommodate either no symmetry
at all or a twofold
rotation access.
Then there was a net that I'll
call the hexagonal net, and
this had T1 identical to T2 in
magnitude, and it had the
angle between them, the angle
between T1 and T2 as
identically 120 degrees.
And this could accommodate
either a threefold or a
sixfold axis.
And then finally, the general
net, which I call a
parallelogram net, and that
has magnitudes of the two
translations not equal
to one another.
They can have any values they
like, and the angle between T1
and T2 is completely general.
And that's exactly what I had
up here for the-- oh, we did
that once already.
The one that I'm missing, the
third one, is the square net.
Square net has T1
identical to T2.
In magnitude, the angle between
them is exactly 90
degrees, and that is required
by a fourfold axis.
Let me pause here to see if
there are any questions.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: When you write on the
last one with the sixfold,
it's only 120.
You could have also written
60, correct?
PROFESSOR: Yes, I could have.
And this lattice is actually the
same as what I found for a
threefold axis.
I could pick either this or this
as the cell, but the two
translations in those
two cells are equal.
And again at various stages
along the way, we'll need a
convention.
And if I have a net that looks
like this, a parallelogram,
whether a specialized
parallelogram or not, I have a
choice of two angles
that I could use.
We call that alpha.
This is going to be 180
degrees minus alpha.
Which do I pick?
You need a rule, and the rule is
that for labeling the cell,
pick alpha so that it's greater
or equal to 90 degrees.
That's pure convention, but you
want to have a rule just
like a language so people use
the same words to describe the
same thing.
Here we want to use the same
geometry to describe one and
the same thing.
The other convention is that
there are no unique
translations that
define a net.
We could take linear
combinations of these vectors
and define the same lattice,
so we need another rule for
selecting the standard
translations--
again, so that two people can
do an x-ray diffraction
experiment and report the
results in terms of the same
lattice, and this is a fairly
reasonable thing.
This is pick the two shortest
translations, and that clearly
makes sense.
There's absolutely nothing at
all to commend a cell that has
this as T2 and this as
T1 so you get a long,
skinny oblique things.
Your natural inclination would
pick the two shortest
translations in the net.
OK, so these are conventions.
This has nothing to do with the
nature of the symmetry or
what makes it unique, but just
so that people have one
defined way of labeling
things.
AUDIENCE: Right.
[INAUDIBLE] my question
was actually that--
PROFESSOR: It was a good answer,
even if was not to the
question that you asked.
AUDIENCE: I said the sixfold and
the threefold are exactly
the same, but then I realized
they are because there is no
crystal that can have threefold
symmetry without sixfold.
PROFESSOR: You were
doing fine.
You should have quit just before
that last statement.
How can you have a hexagonal
lattice that sometimes has
sixfold symmetry and sometimes
has threefold symmetry?
Well, let me give you an example
for that, and it makes
a very useful point.
Let me draw two hexagonal nets,
and in this one I'll put
a threefold axis.
So I'll have one motif here,
I'll go 120 degrees away.
Here is a motif here, and I'll
go 120 degrees away, and here
is a third motif.
So these three guys form
a triangle about
this lattice point.
And we would have about the
other lattice points at the
corners of the cell exactly the
same triangle of motifs,
and the same thing over here.
So there is a pattern.
It has a hexagonal lattice,
and it has a triangle of
objects related by
a threefold axis.
And now let me take exactly the
same lattice, and now I'll
put in instead a sixfold axis.
And that means I'm going to have
a hexagon of objects, and
it'll do something like this.
And I don't want to push my
luck and try to draw that
twice, but there would be a
hexagon here and a hexagon of
motifs here, another one at
this lattice point, and
another one at this lattice
point here.
Same lattice, same shape,
same dimensions--
although that's not critical--
but one of them has only
a threefold axis.
One of them has only a
sixfold axis in it.
Why?
Because I decided to put a
threefold axis in this
pattern, and I decided to put
a sixfold axis in this
pattern, but they both end up
being contented and happy with
a lattice with the same degree
of specialization.
Now we will come as we
progressed a little bit
further that we have to
go in two dimensions
to the reverse situation.
We have a particular symmetry
and it's happy with two
different sorts of lattices
with different shapes and
different specializations,
and that's
going to come up directly.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In this example,
the sixfold [INAUDIBLE]
axis [INAUDIBLE].
It's just that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
You're saying that here hanging
at this lattice point
is something that has
sixfold symmetry.
Here is something has only
threefold symmetry.
The nature of the lattice and
the symmetry that is in that
lattice are two inseparable
aspects of the pattern.
But often, as we've seen here,
there's more than one
possibility for a
given lattice.
And as we'll see very shortly,
for some other symmetries, for
one given symmetry, there are
two kinds of lattices.
But nevertheless, the thing to
keep fixed in your mind is
that we call this a
hexagonal lattice.
Why?
Because this translation is
equal to this one, and they
are exactly 120 degrees apart.
That lattice can have that
specialness only if there's
either a threefold or a
sixfold axis in it.
So the specialization of a
lattice is inseparable from
the symmetry that is in the
lattice that demands that
specialization of the lattice.
Conversely, a lattice can have
the specialization only if you
place in a symmetry which
demands precisely that
specialization.
So if you measure a lattice,
and this turns out to be
119.99 degrees and these turn
out to be 3.21 angstroms and
3.21 angstroms, that is not a
hexagonal lattice, because
there's no symmetry in there
that demands that this angle
be 120 degrees.
And that may seem to be an
academic fine point, but we'll
see that in due course the
properties of a crystal depend
on the symmetry of
that crystal.
If the crystal has symmetry, the
property also has to have
that symmetry.
And it is the atoms inside the
cell which determine the
symmetry of the property, and
the properties is one aspect
of the symmetry that goes along
with lattice dimensions
and lattice angles.
Is that clear?
So let me say it again,
because this is
an important point.
The specialness of a lattice
is inseparable from the
symmetry that is existing in
that lattice that demands that
specialness.
So if you have a crystal with
three orthogonal translations
that is equal in length as you
might care to measure, that
crystal is not cubic unless
there's symmetry in that
lattice that demands that the
edges of the cell conform to
the geometry of a cube.
Any other questions?
Let's then in the time that's
remaining look at the other
symmetry element that could be
present in a two-dimensional
crystal, and that's
the mirror plane.
So here's a mirror plane.
That's the one remaining
symmetry element in two
dimensions, and let's ask how we
might combine in this space
along with the mirror
plane a translation.
If I just pop in a translation,
and call this T1,
and for convenience, I'll take
the lattice point on the
mirror plane.
Here's another lattice
point that sits here.
The mirror plane acts
on everything.
It's going to take this lattice
point and flip it over
to here, and it's going to take
the translation that goes
from the origin lattice point to
this lattice point and give
me a T1 prime that sits here.
And now I have two non collinear
translations, so
these have defined for me a
cell that looks like this.
This is T1, this is T2, and
this is some angle alpha
between them.
That's a special lattice.
This is a lattice which has,
just as in the hexagonal or
square net, two translations
that are
identical in magnitude.
Why?
Because they're repeated by a
mirror plane, and the angle
between them-- the angle
between T1 and T2--
is completely general.
It can be anything it likes.
It can close up to a very narrow
angle or it can open up
to an almost flat angle.
That's a new kind of lattice.
None of the preceding lattices
could make that claim.
Now let me point out that this
is for the first time a case
where it would be much to our
advantage to not choose a cell
that contains one
lattice point.
Let me put some dotted
lines in here.
And let me submit--
these will also be
lattice points--
that I could pick a larger cell
that would have this as
T1, it would have this as T2,
and the angle between them now
would be identically 90
degrees because of the
geometry that gives
us a rhombus here.
This would have two translations
that are not
equal in magnitude, and it would
have an angle between
these two translations that is
identically 90 degrees, but it
is no longer a cell that
contains one lattice point.
It now catches a second
lattice point
that's in the middle.
So this is a double cell, and
it has a rectangular shape.
It's a centered rectangular
lattice.
Being a double cell that's
redundant has twice the area
that is unique in the pattern,
and anything that's hanging up
here is going to be hanging down
here, so it has a twofold
redundancy.
But the thing that you get in
return for paying the price of
that redundancy is a cell that
has a right angle in it.
And as we'll see, we're going
to use the edges of the unit
cell as the basis of a
coordinate system for
describing what goes on at
positions xy within the cell.
And the advantages of an
orthogonal coordinate system,
whenever you can take advantage
of it, far outweighs
the price of pain--
twice the area to describe
the same pattern.
So this is what is generally
taken as the standard cell.
It's a double cell.
But I think you're used to
that sort of compromise,
because you've all heard of face
centered cubic lattices.
The primitive cell in a face
centered cubic lattice is a
rhombohedron.
But, oh, that Cartesian
coordinate system is so great
to use rather than something
that has an
oblique coordinate system.
So is this is a definition
of convenience.
Notice the curious duality--
either special relation between
the translations angle
general or special relation
between the translations, an
angle special.
General translation, special
angle, relation between the
translation, general angle--
so, it's a curious
sort of duality.
You can have one but not the
other or vice versa.
So this is a fourth
sort of lattice.
Number one, number two, number
three, and now we have number
four, which is a centered
rectangular lattice.
And this particular lattice
has T1 not equal to T2 in
magnitude, but it has the
angle between T1 and T2
exactly 90 degrees, and
it's a double cell.
It's centered.
Are we done?
The reason I asked that silly
rhetorical question is that
obviously I suspect that we're
not done, and what
else might we do?
We got our centered rectangular
net by starting
with a translation--
starting with an mirror
plane, really--
and then we added a general
translation, and that
reflected it across and gave us
a diamond shaped net which
we could define as a rectangular
double shell.
Does that always happen?
Do I always get that oblique
diamond shaped cell?
No.
Suppose I put in my first
translation deliberately in a
fashion such that it was at
exactly right angles to the
mirror plane.
That mirror plane will then
reflect the translation and
change its direction, and
now I have generated a
one-dimensional lattice
row with
translational periodicity T1.
And I've got a translation
that's exactly perpendicular
to the mirror plane.
How do I now make a space
lattice, a two-dimensional
space lattice?
And the answer is
very carefully.
Suppose I throw in a second
translation T2 and the mirror
plane reflects it
across to here.
This interval between lattice
points up here is totally in
commensurate with the
first translation,
and that won't work.
It's violated my initial choice
of the translational
periodicity unless I do one of
two things, and let's try them
both and dispose of
this quickly--
this is straight away.
Here's my one-dimensional
lattice row.
I do not violate this
periodicity
T1 if I do two things.
I could pick T2 so that it fell
exactly along the mirror
line, and that's going to
generate for me a new type of
lattice in which this is 90
degrees and these two
translations are unequal
in length.
So this is a lattice that
has a rectangular shape.
It's a primitive rectangular
cell, and it has T1 not equal
to T2 in magnitude, and
it has T1 and T2
exactly 90 degrees apart.
The second choice that would
not result in any
contradiction would be to have
this as T1, and then pick T2
very carefully so that it
spanned the mirror line with
one half of T1 exactly
up here and one half
of T1 exactly here.
And this would be compatible
with the separation T1 down at
the start of this translation.
I think you can see that what
this is going to give me is
the centered rectangular net
right back again, so this is
the centered rectangular net--
nothing new.
But we did pick up one
additional two-dimensional
lattice of distinct character.
Number 5 is a primitive
rectangular network, and it
has the characteristics T1 is
not equal to T2 in magnitude.
Just as in the centered
rectangular net, T1 is at
exactly 90 degrees to T2, but
this is a primitive cell.
And that's it.
We really set up the ground
rules for the geometry of a
periodic two-dimensional
space.
There are five kinds
of rotation axes--
one, two, three,
four, and six.
Each one requires one or
more of the specialized
two-dimensional lattices.
We have a case where
interestingly two different
symmetries are compatible with
a lattice of the same
specialization.
In the case of the [? hexagon ?]
on that, either
three or sixfold symmetry
could require that.
In the case of the mirror plane
we have one symmetry
element, M, that can
fit into two
different kinds of lattices.
So in one case, the same lattice
can take two different
symmetries.
In this case, two different
lattices can accommodate the
same symmetry.
So that's the story for two
dimensions, and we have just
one final thing to do.
That is to add to the lattices
that we have found, and there
are five of them, and add
to the lattice point the
symmetries that we have
found require them.
And there are a limited number
of these-- one, two, three,
four, or sixfold rotational
symmetry in a mirror plane.
And when we have finished these
additions, we will end
up with a combination of lattice
and symmetry, which is
something that is called
a plane group--
group because the operations
that are present in the space
follow the requirements of the
mathematical entity called a
group, plane because this is
a distribution of symmetry
elements throughout a plane
and not just fixed at one
particular point.
Let me finish with some general
observation, and we
will obtain some of these
rules later on.
Suppose I take a pristine
space--
and this blackboard is
no longer pristine--
and I put in the space a
first operation, and
there's a motif in there.
This first operation moves
around this first motif and
gives me a second
one, number two.
Then I say let me put in
another operation.
I'd like to combine these
things and see how many
different combinations
I have, so I put in
operation number two.
Operation number two will take
the second object and repeat
it to a third object.
Number two is identical to
number one, so this gives me a
third object reproduced
from the second by
operation number two.
Now I have a space, and
sitting in it are two
different operations and
three different motifs.
Motif number one and motif
number three are the same darn
thing because they've been
repeated by symmetry steps, so
there must automatically be some
third transformation that
is equal to the combined effect
of going from one to
two and then from
two to three--
going from one to
three directly.
So this is another truth
about these symmetries.
Whenever you take two operations
and combine them in
a space, the net effect of those
two operations is equal
to a third operation.
So a question we're going to ask
all along the way until we
are at the end of the month--
if you take a translation and
combine it with a mirror
plane, what new operation
has to arise?
If you take two rotation
operations and put them
together, what third net
operation has to arrive?
If we have some general rules,
then we can automatically say,
OK, I'm going to take a square
lattice and I'm going to put
in a fourfold axis.
What else is going to pop up
elsewhere within the cell?
We'll be able to do this
systematically but fairly
automatically.
So that's where we're
going from here.
When we're done, we will have
derived systematically and
rigorously the sorts of
symmetries that can combine
symmetries such as rotation and
reflection with a lattice,
and we will know completely
the different sorts of
patterns that exist around
us in two dimensions--
in floor tiles, brick
work, wrapping
paper, and plaid shirts.
We'll pick up at this
point on Thursday.
Let me caution you we are going
into territory that is
not covered in Berger's book.
I've just passed
it out to you.
What we've said in the early
parts of the term are in
there, but we're going to do
things in a slightly different
way and then return to
his text later on.